denise well brian we still do have a
long way to go until
most nevadans are fully vaccinated but
that may be tough
as some are adamant to not get the
vaccine or decided just not to continue
with the second dose
more than 150 000 in clark county have
not completed that second dose
victoria saha joining us now live from
the newsroom with a look at why
victoria denise it's an issue across the
country and right here in nevada as
health officials continue to encourage
people to get vaccinated
some residents are skipping out on their
second dose because they feel like the
first one is enough
or the side effects scared them it's a
topic that's causing a lot of division
to get vaccinated or to not get
vaccinated
but for those like kevin zimmerman who
attempted to get the vaccine
they say they are done just after one i
had the heat on in my apartment
blanket over me sweatshirt on
i'm still like shivering for four days
so i was just like you know what i can't
i can't do it for four more days
zimmerman spoke with me by phone as
saying the side effects from the first
dose he got back in march were too
severe for him to go through it again
but he is disabled and falls under a
vulnerable group that could be
susceptible to the virus and the new
delta variant he now has regrets
i should have just done it and got it
over with you know and
and if i was sick i was sick valerie
matlock is concerned about a second dose
for her daughter due to her bad reaction
doc appriser she got my derma and it
immediately took her out she came home
she was shaking
matlock understands the risks of not
being fully protected and is relying on
the first dose
i'm not willing to risk her going to get
the second dose or she not waking up
health officials say you are protected
against the delta variant only if you're
fully vaccinated
and the two doses of pfizer and moderna
are vital
first dose of the vaccine primes the
immune system
or gets it ready for the infection the
second dose or the booster
magnifies that immune response to really
provide
much more protection against a viral
infection
if you are behind on your second vaccine
health officials say you can still get
your second dose
there is not a cutoff mark but the
sooner the better live in the newsroom
victoria